[Musique]
piétons distraits dadou le voir des plus
en dehors des clos car maintenant c'est
200 francs
et nous ne pourrons plus pour la modique
somme de 20 francs nous payer c'est
peut-être distraction d'un usage courant
que l'administration avait eu le bon
sens d'interdire dans ses règlements
finie la promenade des canards sur les
champs elysées délaissant le vulgaire
c'est pas nous aimions aussi plané
pertuis zano coin satisfaction interdite
c'est 200 francs
pouvait-on rêver plaisir plus délicat
qu'un repas dégusté dans l'intimité de
la rue génie cela aussi c'est 230 aller
faire nos courses à billes en immortel
on n'en parle plus de 100 francs c'est
vraiment trop cher
mais ce que nous regrettons le plus sans
doute c'est notre pain quotidien dans le
bassin de la concorde laurentides où
c'est le soleil caressant
l'agent est encore l'un sans pitié ça
fera deux cents ans monsieur 236 200 par
l'un est encore 200 et on dit que les
cours s'effondrent
[Musique]